eight thousand firefighters are trying
to stop 22 California wildfires from
killing more people windy conditions
this morning are pushing the flames at
least 23 people have died and more than
3500 structures are destroyed nearly 300
people are reported missing but
officials think bad communication may
explain that the wildfires knocked out
power to 77 cell towers this morning
only 13 are now out of service Highway
Patrol officers went door to door last
night encouraging evacuations
Mireya Villarreal and Santa Rosa talked
to one woman who says her family barely
had enough time to escape Maria good
morning
well good morning we are in the Coffee
Park neighborhood one of the hardest hit
areas from this fire where there is
literally nothing left as that fire was
fast approaching on Sunday night
neighbors turned into first responders
going door-to-door to make sure everyone
was safe it's devastating it literally
looks like a bomb went off when Heather
Bowers saw ash raining down in her front
yard Sunday night she became the
neighborhood emergency alert system they
were like what's going on I'm like you
need to pack up her stuff and get out
Bauer's mother and two brothers lost
their homes
her mother escaped him with only the
clothes she was wearing did anybody get
any warnings no many people in the
danger zones were caught by surprise
needed help getting out
[Music]
communication problems in general have
been difficult Noma County Sheriff Roch
Giordano says alerts were sent out but
admits not everyone would have gotten
them a lot of residents are saying they
didn't get any sort of warning what was
the notification process we have systems
that will call landlines for blocks of
area and it will call all of those
houses but now without landlines if you
don't sign your cellphone up you don't
get that service the fires also knocked
out 77 cell phone towers in those cases
Giordano says people should sign up for
Nixle a service used by emergency
responders that can send alerts over
Wi-Fi is there a backup system is there
some back-up plan
news media we want people listen to the
radio pay attention to cell phones get
on the internet go to the webpages use
them all so you don't miss the pieces we
spoke with a family whose aunt has been
missing since Sunday a hotel employee
five towns over saw that report
recognize the woman and helped us
reunite the family Nixle says they sent
out four million messages since the fire
started so clearly this has taken a
combination of efforts to make sure
everyone stays safe
Norah Wow such reporting there I hope
everyone can find their missing loved
ones and relatives Thank You Maria